[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sli fällt am
mittwoch hatte er mit murat das
vergnügen mit dem smos rezept und heute
bin ich wieder da es gibt eine
frankfurter kranz rolle die sich sarah
gewünscht hat ok sarahs und somit seinen
abstürze die wünscht sich fast jeden
kuchen und meist immer käsekuchen aber
heute eine frankfurter kranz rolle das
ganze besteht aus einem biscuit und es
geht auch ein bisschen schneller als so
ein typischer frankfurter kranz und ich
habe noch eine neuigkeit für euch zeige
ich euch gleich für den teig verwende
ich feiere etwas vanille extrakt eine
prise salz 100 gramm zucker 100 vom bug
mail und 100 gramm gehackte gerüstete
haselnüsse die neuigkeit ist unser
backen wir haben endlich unser eigenes
mail und dieses ist ganz bald schon in
jeder lidl filiale zu finden ich bin
richtig glücklich und zwar kam uns die
idee weil ich doch immer dieses ganz
ganz feine mail hatte was eben nicht
geliebt werden muss und jetzt am bug
mail gemacht war einfach schon
backpulver auch mit drin steckt das
heißt wenn ihr rezepte macht wie muffins
rückbuchen waffeln pancakes gebäck
jeglicher art müsst ihr keine backpulver
mehr dazu geben denn hier ist einfach
die perfekte mischung schon vorbereitet
und ihr habt keine über und keine
unterdosierung ich zeige euch das jetzt
einfach mal jetzt nehmt ihr einfach die
eier die sollten am besten zimmer warm
sein danach sie sich besser aufschlagen
und die könnt ihr hier mit vanille exakt
salz und zucker schön cremig verrühren
und es dauert so ungefähr zehn minuten
mit einer guten küchenmaschine gerne
auch ein bisschen weniger einem
handrührgerät auch mal ein bisschen
länger also rührte ruhig so lange es
geht damit der bis kitsch in luftig wird
aber da jetzt hier im bug mail auch
backpulver drin ist ist auch mal okay
wir fünf minuten aufgehört ansonsten
nimmt man ja oder braucht man gar kein
backpulver imbiss wird aber mit
backpulver spart man sich das langen
röhren
noch vorher anschalten
[Musik]
das war's schon guckt mal so solltet ihr
es aussehen richtig schön cremig echt so
glaube ich so ein bisschen wie sag ich
da eigentlich keinen viel wissen aber im
sturm hatte ich da schon ganz oft dass
er irgendwie schaumig und cremig
verwechselt und schaue mich ist es wenn
es eben schau mir hier so noch flüssig
und es ist so richtig dick cremig also
fast schon wie steiff geschlagenes
eiweiß aber
das stimme ich will immer gar nicht so
sehr auf klären weil das immer punkt
dass noch nicht alles
falsch macht keinen spaß
sorry sturm
und jetzt ist mail nehmen wie gesagt
wenn jetzt backend müsst ihr es nicht
sieben ihr seht schon es ist ganz fein
puttrich wenn ihr ganz normales mail
nimmt dann auf jeden fall 7 und dann
ganz vorsichtig unterheben
jetzt habe ich den ofen schon vorgeheizt
und
habe jetzt hier meinen backbleche
könnten herkömmliches neben oder ebenso
ein bug rahmen tabaks ein bisschen
schneller und da gebe ich jetzt die
haselnüsse rein
die sicherung geröstet und gehabt aber
so richtig einfach nochmal im ofen mit
und die hälfte verteile ich jetzt
darunter und hilft obendrauf
da kommt jetzt der schöne luftige
biscuit rein und wird dann einmal schön
glatt gestrichen jetzt soll doch alles
relativ zügig gehen der biscuit muss
nämlich gleich in den backofen und
deswegen musste er auch schon vorgeheizt
[Musik]
jetzt ist schon fertig da wird nämlich
ganz heiß und ganz kurz gebacken das
ganz wichtig damit er gleich beim
aufräumen nicht reißt und jetzt auch
wirklich direkt auslösen das heißt
einmal vom backblech ziehen
dann den rand lösen
[Musik]
und dann nehmt ihr euch eine saubere
geschirrtuch und stürzt das ganze da
drauf
einmal mutig sein und
jetzt sofort abziehen
[Musik]
und dann könnt ihr das ganze sogar schon
ein bisschen aufrollen damit der schon
weiß in welche richtung ist gleich geht
ich habe jetzt hier auch schon die
zutaten gerichtet die zeit nutze ich
immer ganz gerne die backzeit und kann
jetzt nämlich gleich den pudding
herstellen für die buttercreme ihr könnt
die frankfurter kranz rolle auch mit
einer sahne creme füllen das ist euch
überlassen also ein typischer
frankfurter kranz hat schon so eine
deutsche buttercreme deswegen machen wir
jetzt erstmal den pudding und dann die
buttercreme gedacht okay
für die buttercreme nämlich 340 gramm
milch 60 gramm zucker etwas vanille
extrakt 30 gramm stärke 2 eigelbe und
220 gramm butter die darf gern schon
weich sein wenn ihr kennwort habt dann
könnt ihr den pudding theoretisch auch
in der kennwort zubereiten ich mag sie
zierte cdu zieht ein bisschen milch in
den topf geben und
dann auch direkt zucker und vanille dazu
viele machen so dass sie erst mal die
milch aufkochen lassen den rest für ihn
ich muss sagen ich will mir gleich alles
zusammen das geht auch am anfang erstmal
stärke und aigle mit ein wenig milch
anrühren dass es nicht klumpt und dann
den rest dazu geben
und jetzt einfach schön verrühren dann
den herd auf mittel herzustellen und
während des führens den pudding schön
einkochen
jetzt machen was bauer
außerdem macht sie das stumme power
boost aber dann brennt euch kaputt macht
oder nicht
sieht gut aus
so da kann ich jetzt feierabend machen
also wenn es einmal klub dann kann man
das hier um viel denn vor dem
besuch der schau also wieso muss ja so
schaut der bürgerschaft
zu lange
auf mich zu drücken
zugleich geht es schneller als du jetzt
wird's schon fest
schön batterie
sehr gut als ich würde sagen sie in zwei
jahren
ab dem nächsten jahr übernimmt samira
daran denkt oder
ist okay bin ich aber keine freizeit
mehr morgens stimme nachmittags dreht
und ich gehen urlaub
finden ja
ok die gleichen anzusehen
kann ich jetzt noch einen auf stuhl
mittwoch gegen zug
mein papa macht was er am besten kann
der kärcher draußen
du darfst dir überlegen übrigens was du
nächste woche montag für ein rezept
machen möchtest ein kluger kopf
jetzt kommen doch okay jetzt der pudding
fertig und kann umgefüllt werden
ich wollte vertuschen
und ich fühlte mich direkt in seinen
teller damit er schnell abkühlen kann
aber einmal
kurz in die spüle lägen
details
sorgen jetzt hier direkt umfeld schön an
der oberfläche abdecken damit sich keine
haut bildet entweder mit einer
frischhaltefolie oder mit so einem
silikon deckel am besten da spart man
ein bisschen die folie muss echt sagen
dass ich komplett eigentlich das
komplett auf alufolie unsere ställe
folie verzichtet
trotzdem immer da so eine rolle aber ich
brauche dich echt gar nicht mehr
außerdem sinkt und da ging alles schief
den lassen wir jetzt auf raumtemperatur
abkühlen dann warte ich noch kurz auf
die butter bis sie ganz warm ist und
dann geht es gleich weiter nicht der
brutto kranke mal abspielen
die pro tag könnte jetzt schön weiß
creme rühren das ist auch wichtig bei
einer buttercreme ich meine die heißt so
aber die muss nicht unbedingt nach
butter schmecken und ich glaube das
machen die wenigsten dass sie die mutter
dann lange genug rühren denn dann ist
der pro tag geschmack dieser intensive
geschmack einfach weg und wenn sie schön
weiß cremig ist dann ist sie auch
luftiger und eben nicht so kompakt und
fest das heißt die wird jetzt hier
gleich verrührt so etwa fünf minuten und
der pudding sieht so aus okay sie das
erst mal nicht appetitlich aus aber den
für rühre ich jetzt mache
und dann kommt er da gleich esslöffel
weise dazu
und wenn ihr seht dass der pudding
nachdem verrühren noch so kleine
klümpchen habt dann streicht den am
besten durch ein haar sehen ich hab
gedacht ich kam zu vermeiden aber einige
streichen durch dann schmeckt besser
[Musik]
und jetzt ist die buttercreme schon
fertig da ist auch eigentlich nur zu
beachten dass die butterweich ist und
der pudding aber auch abgekühlt ist er
darf nicht ganz kalt sein also nicht
kühlschrank kalt sonst kritzelt das
ganze der pudding darf aber auch nicht
wahr sein und schnell ist die butter
also einfach beides raumtemperatur jetzt
kann ich das hier kurz aus garbsen die
maschine weg stellen und dann wird der
kuchen schaum gefüllt geht also recht
schnell da habe ich jetzt also den
abgekühlten bis wird hab hier noch eine
marmelade denn ich bin typ mensch ich
brauche mal laden frankfurter tanz ich
weiß manchmal uns auch ohne aber dann
finde ich den frankfurter kranz schon
ein bisschen langweilig muss ich sagen
und ich habe jetzt hier
ich habe jetzt ihre himbeermarmelade mit
johannisbeergelee gemischt so ein
bisschen für die farbe und den geschmack
ihr könnt aber auch marmelade eurer wahl
nehmen ich muss sagen ich mag den
frankfurter kranz am liebsten mit
himbeermarmelade
deswegen nämlich dass
ihr könnt ihr noch schreiben was ihr
gerne mit
das war mehr gemischte salate mit tonga
das ist gut und jetzt vorsichtig
auseinander rollen
ich mag biskuitrolle
und dann kommt da erstmal den marmeladen
schicht rein
und damit optisch auch ganz ganz schön
wird und quasi ganz in der mitte auch
marmelade landet müsst ihr wirklich hier
bis hoch an den rand das ist ja das
zentrum der biskuitrolle
ein bisschen was habe ich noch aus
und da ist eine frische palette nehmen
oder die palette zwischen
hier erstmal hier unter den anfang
dass da kein knick macht
und der rest darf dann hinzu strichen
werden und für den rand nehme ich immer
gern so eine tankkarte dann klettere ich
denke ich nicht nach außen
jetzt wird das ganze aufgewickelt da
könnte jetzt auch das tuch so ein
bisschen zur hilfe nehmen
und jetzt hier schön rund und
eng aufräumen
so schön es
perfekt runter
und bevor ich jetzt aber dekoriert denn
jetzt ist ja die butter noch einstellig
sie in den kühlschrank und so etwa eine
stunde oder
20 minuten griff und dann kann ich sie
nämlich mit der restlichen creme fertigt
dekorieren
kontrollieren und dann kühl stellen
ich leg bis getreuen die gehen immer
schnell sind schön online
und damit wir natürlich auch aussieht
wie eine frankfurter kranz rolle und
auch so schmeckt bekommt sie außen rum
bis hin zu kantig habe hier solltet
karamarko kant ich glaube das schmeckt
richtig gut aber damit nicht so süß ist
denn ich bin nicht so ganz süße also bei
torten schon aber es muss immer so ein
bisschen im verhältnis sein mich das
ganze mit haselnüssen die eben auch
gehackten gerüstet sind und deswegen
kommt da jetzt erstmal eine kleine
schicht
drumherum
einfach damit der krug hand halten kann
und der rest kommt damit in dem
spritzbeutel
wobei ich sie so schön fand also wenn
ihr da jetzt nichts mehr drum rum haben
wollt dann packt einfach die creme in
spritzbeutel spritzen drauf aber ich
finde kann muss schon danach gefragt
futter trans rolle
schön auch bis nach unten
ich habe eigentlich auch so eine riesige
palette aber ich mag das kleine werkzeug
das hier erstmal freie sorten schön
vermischen
da könnte wirklich schön am rand
anfangen hier unten und immer wieder mit
datei karte des so dran drücken einmal
rechts einmal links und dann der rest
eben hier oben drauf
das geht jetzt schon länger aus und
dafür nehme ich jetzt so eine kleine
thüle die ist so ein bisschen flach
abgerundet mit zacken direkt hier mit
dem adapter an dem spritzbeutel dran
war und der ständig das versteck so groß
dass wir jetzt so
und dann fühle ich da die creme ein
schmeckt hier nämlich gerade dass die
buttercreme sind so reich ist deswegen
denkt dass kurz auf ein körper und kann
aber in der zwischenzeit hier schon mal
eine kleine markierung machen zum einen
damit ich weiß wo ich die creme auch
spritze und zum anderen hält die creme
ist hier auf dem kopf und nicht und wenn
man einen frankfurter kranz macht der
hunde ist da nimmt man auch einfach mit
einem löffel die kokang schicht oben weg
und thema war das jetzt einfach so
so ein bisschen krokant unternehmen
[Musik]
und jetzt mit der gezackten seite nach
oben ansetzen und so kleine wellen auf
spritzen
und bevor ich die johannisbeere drauf
setzte stelle ich den frankfurter kranz
einfach nur meinen kühlschrank damit die
buttercreme fest damit ich jetzt drauf
setzt dann zerstöre ich die schönen
tupfen und dann bin ich fertig und kann
probiert werden
[Musik]
und jetzt die rolle fertig und ich lasse
meine girls probieren
was singen
und tanzen ein ok
ok hab ich ja viel zu essen ja
allerdings von ihrem mit einer wohnung
in eure gold
wir sind fasziniert von dieser rolle
sind von der rolle
der klassiker ist da dran war nicht das
erste mal gegessen habe war ich habe
immer die fakten raus willkommen zwar
gleich mit wir dann hat deiner oma com
ist ein backbuch
die frankfurter kranz städte du bist
manchmal wie meine oma
mir gab es jetzt auch gesehen
hatte es vorher noch nie gegessen und
dann in deinem buch also ist hier ja und
durch getan aber ich habe schon als kind
gerne das ist ewig mein mut und her
immer gemacht hat die mit marmelade oder
ohne
ohne also seid ihr eher themen ohne
marmelade gesagt das weiß ich nicht ich
probiert jetzt und fertigen sarah marx
eine fruchtstückchen aber marmelade
glaube ich mache mir da den medien gern
probiert man sich wunderbar es dauert
halt immer ein bisschen länger so ein
frankfurter kranz zu machen aber so eine
rolle das gehört sich nicht geschlagen
und so schnell ist die torte zerstört
der krokant außen das ist solltet carla
bruni
also ob es wieder klassiker schnell kann
ich nicht sagen ich bin gut ich denke ja
wieder klein
bisschen lockerer
in der masse noch locker fahren will
kann meiner stadt buttercreme eine sahne
creme mit mascarpone oder quark mit
frischkäse nicht blinkt und
jakub ehrlich ich finde es sogleich
toter körper dazu aber auch so sollte
ich finde es dass das süß salzige link
bisschen von dem inneren ab ebenso
geschmack der zeit grad klasse nicht
dass unser kontrast zu dem süß salzig
und die sauren gehandelt werden dazu
meinem haus gut erklärt jeder seine
meinung aber ich mag es heute carmel
aber ich glaube ich wird es nächstes mal
ohne sollte ich finde schmecken nach
sorte können will und ich finde dass
jetzt einfach so richtig mal was anderes
ich glaube mir schneiders jetzt jedoch
noch ein stück runter ja ein café kaffee
den raus in die sonne bestimmt die
scheint mal wieder und ich haben wollte
probieren
ich hatte heute den westen und jetzt
eigentlich so wo bleibt sein luftiges
kleid mega das rezept gibt es wie immer
in meiner app könnt ihr gerne nachlesen
das rezept auch gerne nachmachen ich
glaube das wird wieder ein rezept ruhig
ich habe euch gestern ja schon die
zutaten genannt also viel spaß beim
sofort mit backen wir müssen es nur
aufschreiben ist uns bei der sich weil
es echt zudem sonntags rezept passiert
sofort mit backen könnt und dann könnt
ihr mir gleich die bilder in die story
hochladen und chancen und ressourcen
bekommen
die hält solange
[Gelächter]
ich backe gerne nehme ich die halbe mit
am sonntag und sagt ich sage ich habe
mich dann einspringen
das stück habe ich kann guten kaffee die
maschine kann guten kaffee
träger maschine ist ein vollautomat also
ich friere die eigenen geschmack mit den
frisch
[Musik]